in this video we're going to talk about
energy and in particular we're going to
talk about the energy of life the energy
that i need to live and all of us need
to live the energy you need to think the
energy i'm using to make this video
right now
and some of you might already guess
where this energy is coming from
the surface of our planet is constantly
being bombarded with light energy from
the sun
and you might know that there's certain
organisms on our planet that are capable
of taking that light energy and then
storing it as chemical energy
and those things and there's many types
but the ones that we see most often in
our day-to-day life are plants and so
let's imagine a plant here
and what it's doing is it's using that
light energy in conjunction with water
typically from
the soil that maybe it's getting through
its roots and carbon dioxide in the air
and it's using that light energy to
actually stick
or you could say fix the carbon to
construct itself
and in its own tissue it's storing that
energy and then if it were to break down
that tissue it can release that energy
in various forms
now as it does this you might also be
familiar that these photosynthesizers or
these primary producers or these
autotrophs they're also releasing
molecular oxygen
now if we were to describe this in in
chemical terms or chemistry terms we
would describe this process of
photosynthesis as taking carbon dioxide
from the air in conjunction
with water
from the soil
and what's i guess you could say fueling
all of this is light energy
usually from
the sun
and what that is yielding
is
the tissue of the plant that is actually
storing that energy is chemical energy
in an organic form and the primary the
primary way that this is done is through
glucose which is
c6h12o6 i know what you're thinking all
plants don't taste sweet well if you
take chains of sugars and put them
together you get carbohydrates and you
adapt them a little bit you get things
like starches and that's what most of
the plant tissue is so some variations
of this or thing variations of this
linked together but this is where the
energy is stored so energy
stored in the actual plant tissue and
then of course it releases
that molecular oxygen
and this
is the process
of photosynthesis
and even if you look at the word
photosynthesis
and what the parts of it mean photo is
referring to light and synthesis is
referring to putting something together
synthesizing something so photosynthesis
you're using light to put together these
essentially fix the carbon together to
store energy
now you might say all right that's nice
i'm storing the energy this way how do i
actually use the energy and that's
something that all of us are doing all
living systems have to do and that
process is respiration
and you could already guess what at
least the chemical
the chemical
reaction for respiration will look like
you're going to start with our stored
energy our glucose cac6h12o6
in the presence of oxygen and since
we're respiring all the time this is why
we need to breathe oxygen
and this is going to yield
carbon dioxide and that's why
we exhale more carbon dioxide than we
inhale it's also going to release
water and it's going to release and this
is the whole point of it
cellular
energy and in other videos that you'll
see in a biology class we'll talk about
how this form of stored energy gets
converted to other forms and then how
that's used by the various machinery and
cells to actually live to reproduce to
move in many cases
now an interesting question is how do
you measure how much photosynthesis is
going on how much primary productivity
is going on
well one way to think about it is
find an ecosystem and take a certain
area
of the surface of that ecosystem and it
could be a terrestrial ecosystem on land
it could be a marine ecosystem and then
say
for this area in a given period of time
often times a year how much stuff is
growing so this is the stuff that grows
and obviously or it would seem that the
more stuff that is growing
that the more photosynthesis that is
taking place
and the way that they measure how much
how much
is growing you can either measure it in
terms of grams of biomass so grams of
biomass and biomass is just a fancy way
of saying that the mass of biological
stuff that's just growing on this area
and usually they'll take the water out
so they get a consistent measurement or
you can convert this to
calories and it's usually measured in
thousands of calories kilocalories and
when you see calories on a packaging
food label what we most of us think of
calories those are actually kilocalories
when we think about it in scientific
terms
and i know what you're thinking you're
like wait mass and kilocalories calories
that's just a form of energy well those
two things you can go between because
usually a certain type of biomass a gram
of a certain type of biomass will have a
certain amount of energy stored in it
not energy that necessarily all animals
could use or that we could use but it
does have energy in it
now when we talk about this primary
productivity
you might already be thinking about well
doesn't
don't the plants need to use some of the
energy that they are producing
themselves to live
and my answer to you is of course they
need it in fact that's probably the most
important reason why they need to
photosynthesize is because they need to
do respiration in order for them to grow
and metabolize and live and reproduce
and so when you see how much has been
produced in a given area in a given year
you're actually seeing the net primary
productivity this is the you could think
about it how much photosynthesis they
did minus how much respiration they did
so if you think of how much
photosynthesis they did as gross primary
productivity so that's the total amount
of photosynthesis and then you subtract
out
the amount of
energy
chemical energy or cellular energy they
needed for respiration that would then
give you the net
primary
productivity
and as i mentioned
just to make things a little bit
tangible if you took a very productive
ecosystem let's say something like a
rain forest that i have here in the
background a very productive ecosystem
like this
if you were to take on average
a
square
meter of this
it produces in a year
about 2000 grams of biomass
so here we would say that the net
primary productivity of this rainforest
that you see in the background here
would be approximately 2000
grams
per
square meter per
year
and if you wanted to think about this in
terms of kilocalories you just have to
say well
each gram of biomass is how many
kilocalories and it depends on the type
of biomass but let's say that we have
four kilocalories per gram
of biomass so then we could also say
that this net primary productivity is
equal to 2000
grams per square meter per year
times
4
kilocalories
per gram the grams cancel out and then
you multiply 4 times 2 000 that's going
to be 8000
kilocalories
kilocalories per square meter
per
year that would be the net primary
productivity because that's after the
plants have been doing respiration now
how would you figure out gross primary
productivity well you're not going to be
able to do it directly but you can
figure that out by figuring out the rate
of respiration if you took some plants
in that ecosystem and then you put them
in a dark room with no light and then if
you saw how much oxygen they are
absorbing or they're having to use then
that gives you a sense of how much
respiration they are doing and there's
ways that you can look at the ratios of
the oxygens and the carbons to figure
out exactly how much respiration is
going on and then if you know the net
primary productivity and the rate of
respiration then you could figure out
the gross primary productivity
but i will leave you there because these
are really useful measurements well one
it's really useful to think about where
all of the energy that allows us to live
comes from but it's also useful for
ecologists to think about how productive
a system is or what's making it more
productive or less productive and as
we'll see these numbers here these are
for sure on the high end of
net primary productivity if we were in a
desert type of ecosystem
this number might be in the low hundreds
and not in the 8 000 range